all right aria yes aria where'd you grow
up where are you from originally i'm
from miami florida born and raised miami
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents as a kid yes um my
parents are in a very happy loving
marriage there's always their bad times
but
i'm the youngest of five
and my dad's first marriage there's
three kids uh two girls and a boy
marty sandy and glenn and then my full
half i mean my full brother matthew so
he's only a year older than me so and
how would you describe your childhood
um
[Music]
it was because i'm pretty happy
it was happy
until i kind of started realizing things
about
the world and stuff i mean like growing
up
um i was just kind of
i never really like knew like the
difference between like a boy and a girl
like i kind of just well to previous out
there i'm transgender woman
so growing up
i like always just gravitated towards
princesses like my favorite was ariel
and it wasn't until i kind of started
realizing like this isn't quote unquote
like normal according to society
that i kind of just
started like getting more unhappy
and kind of like
i kind of just made my own life out to
be worse than it actually was because
looking back at it my parents they were
very supportive i mean like incredibly
for like the time like my dad grew up in
1953 he's from the bronx and for him to
come to terms with
this and like
they kind of just realized like i'd
rather have
a
an alive daughter than a dead son
and they've been
my greatest fans and i honestly regret
how much
i despise them for no reason it was just
really just like
i made out my life to be
tragic i always i've always found myself
romanticizing
tragedy
and i've kind of been needing to break
out of that it's a big generational
difference a big generation for for the
younger generation like how old are you
i'm only 18. you're only 18. yeah so
you're you're you're one of the younger
ones that
i see a lot of
young people that are
trans or
just blurring the lines between
their sex of their sexuality their their
identity what they identify as
and the older generation is very stuck
in their ways a man is a man a woman is
a woman so it it's nice that your father
was able to
come around yeah i mean
my dad's like he's a doctor so he's
always just been about science
and i think it's really just we have to
like get out and educate people because
it wasn't until we sat down with my
gender therapist and my endocrinologist
that we kind of just like learned about
like
okay like there's literally like stuff
that happens like when a baby's being
made in the stomach that kind of like
influences how things can turn out and
there's stuff about the genomes and the
chromosomes it's a whole very
interesting topic that i'm not educated
enough on but
there's great resources out there shout
out to dr marilyn voger she's
one of the smartest people i've ever had
the privilege of meeting
and
you
somebody tell me about your your
schooling and you know
you what kind of kid were you in high
school basically okay in high school
that's actually when i came out as
transgender it was
i believe my freshman year
and i went to an art school
i went to an art school with only 500
kids at most and we were it was very
liberal in high school in high school in
high school so i grew up in a bubble i
would say my
bullying experience it wasn't really
high school fortunately
but it was really just honestly since
pre-k up to eighth grade
i just remember being called a [ __ ]
and all these terrible things and
just really like
being like looked at and
to me like i never associated myself
like as a gay man because like i never
really saw myself as a man i've always
been a woman in my brain
so
you were born this way i was born this
way nothing changed it wasn't like
it was literally until like
my parents were kind of just like you're
a boy and i was like what like
what like i would show up to preschool
and
ariel's costume like i always just
wanted to be beautiful
and
yeah and you are thank you
and
living in miami compared to new york how
how is that how are you treated
differently or okay honestly my biggest
culture shock is when i was in miami
everyone was like girl wait till you got
to new york you're going to thrive there
you're going to be so happy everyone's
going to open you with these arms and
honestly been
very much the opposite
i'm actually a concern for my safety
here i mean
yes there's really
i've experienced the most hatred being
here
and like i've never been scared for my
life until i came to new york city
it wasn't until i was walking down the
street on first avenue by myself no i
wasn't with i was with friends and it
was
we were going out to a bar and
this man he was like
damn mommy so sexy and then
i kind of was just like i like said
something to my friend and he heard my
voice and he was just like that's a man
and he was chasing me down the street
and i was
i literally was like telling my friend i
was like i'm about to get hate crime i'm
gonna get shot i'm gonna be like this is
how i die this is how i die and i just
remember like calling my mom crying
being like i don't feel safe here like i
want to go home
so
it's been hard and
i'm scared but um
it's just scary
yeah
but there is it's it's really cool here
it's really during night i guess when i
feel most different from my life right
you're going to school here i am going
to school here i go to school at parsons
and i am a fashion design major
yes and
new york is where i always knew i had to
be yeah i would think
being a fashion designer it just new
york and this the the colleges here are
probably the best way for you to oh no
for sure to pursue that
and you i mean it's interesting you have
that reaction because some i've
interviewed other
people who are in your situation
in terms of their with how they identify
and they've said it's been really great
for them
here well yeah i think i guess i'm kind
of
not yeah i would say spoiled in that
sense that in miami it's actually kind
of liberal
that the worst that would happen is that
occasionally sometimes uh
my pronouns would be mixed up or
something but like
i had the privilege of like passing and
stuff
like i guess to most people
so it was kind of just like
i never really experienced anything that
bad in miami
so
like don't get me wrong it's not like
it's like terrible here that everyone's
like
like let me just put it this way i'd be
way worse off in ohio or something oh
yeah for sure for sure but um
i guess people are just a lot more
violent here well there's all kinds of
people here there's all kinds of people
i think you can walk through washington
square park where i met you
yeah and uh
[Music]
no one's gonna give you a hard time yeah
but if you go out into certain
neighborhoods
where maybe
culturally they're not as sophisticated
as maybe this neighborhood
you could get into trouble
for sure and then maybe that's where
those kind of things happen to you yeah
that's true
but you have friends you've made here
and oh no yes i've had lovely friends um
i actually came here with my best friend
from high school she's my roommate so
i've been very fortunate to have her
that's great holding my hand
but um
i felt like since i came to new york
there's kind of been like this wall
between me and like my actual happiness
like i think i was expecting more from
it and i think that's just because
during the summer i got my heart broken
and it was my first heartbreak oh i'm
sorry
it's life it's life that's that's how
love works you learn
yes
but it's nice that you can even meet
somebody and and have that opportunity
here no yeah in ohio you probably
wouldn't definitely not no
so i'm very grateful yeah
i think i just always focus on the
negative i don't know like i said before
i like to romanticize tragedy which i
really shouldn't be doing do you have
bouts with depression or other emotions
i do
um
i
i guess it's just like
i get really sad and i kind of lose hope
for seconds
and i lose faith
and i've really just been like
having a better relationship just with
like
god and like my spiritual like aspect
and like my mother she grew up very
religious
in the best way possible though like
more spiritual than religious
so i'm very happy that i've kind of just
been like accepting more of that you
know i have my crystals and my evil eye
on me
but um
no yeah i've
i'm
trying to start thinking more positive
than negative yeah that would help
mm-hmm because it's easy to focus on the
negative very and as as a transgender
woman you'll you'll you'll encounter a
lot of that there's a lot of negativity
but if you can stay positive you can
just write through it right know it's
coming and
not let it get to you
exactly i've had to develop very thick
skin and
everyone who meets me
they always tell me i'm the strongest
person they know and i think that's what
scares me is that i feel so weak
but um
i guess looking at it from an outside
professor perspective i am strong and
i'm very fortunate
that this did happen to me sometimes i
wish i was just born regular but where's
the fun in that
you like challenges i do
what uh what would you say is your
biggest regret
my biggest
honestly
i don't really
and you don't have to have regrets i
think a lot of the people ask that
question of answer me that they don't
have regrets yeah i would say that every
like everything has happened for a
reason in my life every step that i've
taken has lead me to where i am yeah
that's a great attitude i would say like
the only regret i do have is like oh my
god i was such a [ __ ] to my parents
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] and i regret that
i do i that's a that's a good regret to
have yeah i love them so much i'm sure
they love you and and for you to treat
them
it like it didn't like i feel so bad and
like now that they're not here with me
like they're back in miami
but all i want to do is just like hug
and kiss them and spend time with them
that's great
and what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned
in life yeah
most importantly even though you're
still a kid even though yeah i'm still a
child um
i guess um
well i learned an important lesson
in relation to kind of like relationship
wise or like kind of just like being
with someone is just like
i always like
you can't overthink things and i think
that's a good aspect or a good lesson to
kind of bring into everything into life
because i'm always the worrier and i
overthink things to the
like you'll say hi to me and i'll be
like okay what does this mean what does
that mean
there's like lyrics and songs that's
just like i overthink your punctuations
and like shout out lord
and that's literally yeah you just can't
overthink things sometimes a simple
hello is just a simple hello and same
thing with the goodbye that's great
wonderful
all right aria thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much and
i wish you the best of luck in new york
city and whatever you do from here thank
you thank you very much
you